[Music]
you want to know what though I actually
hate horror films I can't stand
only because I get so scared of what are
these people who holds like a pillow in
front of my face and balls my eyes out
particular Series in the house seems to
me that female roles within horror films
if it's not a slash or horror film the
characters tend to be very strong and
very empowered because they tend to
start out probably as the weakling or as
the stocked and by the end are able to
overcome that and take over
not in my movie
hi Gail weathers field correspondent E.T
was there when David Arquette and
Courtney Cox fell for each other on set
in 1996.
now what Courtney like to work with oh
Courtney's great yeah she's incredible
she's very witty and on her feet and
she's got an incredible sense of humor
she's a stunning to look at I mean if
David Arquette's working then pretty
much you don't have to do anything you
just sit back and watch you know I got
me a small part on this movie he liked
to streak a lot I went on my way we went
into the trailer tonight we played Gail
weather's clothes on him
they said please go down to the sets the
middle of a day can you open up his Cody
was wearing like Gail weather's entire
suit that's a little fighting for me to
say that he can actually fit into my
skirt but he did I'm making a really
scary Gail Weathers
I know it's ridiculous and I wouldn't do
that now of course they're just friends
now but here's something you might not
know this 10 minute scene with Drew
Barrymore took 10 16 hour days to shoot
oh God I like to do the crying the
screaming the hyperventilation I mean
you there isn't a lithium in the world
that can carry you the way you feel and
with the amount of crying I did the cult
favorite franchise has spawned five
movies over 25 years earning over 744
million bucks at the box office so
what's next Scream Six it'll follow the
ghost face survivors as they leave
Woodsboro behind for a fresh chapter
production is wrapped and the film is
expected to arrive next march Courtney
is returning with the stars of scream 5.
Hayden Panettiere will reprise her
Scream 4 character Kirby but a salary
dispute is keeping Nev Campbell's Sydney
on the sidelines for now it's a very
hard decision to make as a woman I think
it's really important that we try to be
on par financially with men and I really
just didn't feel that what was offered
to me really equated to the value that I
bring to these films so is the door
completely closed there they care about
these movies if they were to come to me
with an amount that felt in keeping with
you know as I said the value that I
bring then I would certainly consider it
thank you